you don't know spéciaux se trouve sur
ben voila je vous avais dit qu'on ferait
deuxième et deux sur ce jeu puisque je
l'avais adorée ses partisans à faire si
le bel comme la dernière fois le web
bien s'en sortir par go now c'est quoi
ça ça jamais vu avant ok on y va ah ok
des petits coups d'accords le bon vieux
hall d'entrée de jeu on m'aurait jamais
à temps c'est passé lyon embrun vous
avez vu ça on a tous passé trail qui l'a
alors là les nouveaux éléments on peut
lire ça par exemple c'est nouveau la
seule fois où on a vu ça c'est dans les
coulisses du grand rex à paris pour ceux
qui connaissent et un truc comme ça
aussi c'est nouveau ça à ses parents on
continue à les sans problème sans
problème oh [ __ ] ils agressif lui ça
c'est un homme mal baisées ça ça je
voulais regarder
ok ok question à faire
vas-y vas-y vas-y tu es frustré un
hoquet j'aimais aller avec check point
d'annoncer un [ __ ] labit raj est trop
crucial checkpoint qui est juste là en
vrai nous ont bien eu à la regarde et
vous est ce petit chemin là et ouais on
s'en doute pas mais il mène à la sortie
je me demande quel va être le boss de ça
je n'ai pas vu je crois qu'on est obligé
d'aller là bas je vais y retourner avec
les gens mal baisées la [ __ ] j'ai eu
chaud mais avant ces faits ok on va
passer là à aal au niveau c'est plus
simple price non mais quel autre site
mais mouvement quoi il a beaucoup trop
jouer à battlefield
en fait ils le font deux fois 1 2 la
prime de passer voilà là y'a plus qu'à
aller ici adroit dans le petit truc
qu'on était alors on va faire garder
cette lame là il est discrète c'est une
lame d'assassins savoie la plate forme
plate forme plate forme plate mais avec
des formats oxymore un excellent moment
à votre problème française qui en
occident le culot maintenant ben ouais
y'a des gens ils ont pas attendre un but
dans la vie moi j'ai pas de temps à
prendre
ok j'ai perdu un bras tout mon temps
baytech même lui un comment on fait pour
s'accomplir avec comme ça je fais une
roulade au hall et fdp
[ __ ] on est chaud ça passe assez
embiez un peu valu à ces traîtres
nos bateaux camotos hockey tels faits
victimes par une boule barrette
oh là là se rechargent étaient d'une
ben voila j'ai pas de répartir gens
minces mais doit on la fait pareil dans
la vie vous verrez ça marche à chaque
fois on est bien on est bien on alors ça
on a dit on y aller au culot comme d'hab
jean-michel par l'instinct cas ça
exemple céder l'âme c'est chiant c'est
pas des vieilles poules inutile hall
alors moi même je sais pas ce que le
fait que [ __ ] ce que c'était bon ça
c'était chose qui tarde de boules la
halle et le vin lui depuis que ça si
vous postez un peu trop simple à mon
goût qui se sait que ça c'est normal ça
peut-être pas au nom à ol sam devriez
mettre un panneau amont pour prévenir
attention tu peux perdre en sautant dans
ce trou au printemps c'est la [ __ ] à
les avaler ça va aller à g sur le coin
du kram dit ok faut bien rester dans le
trou voilà c'est bon ça parfait les
lancers personne ne peut l'arrêter bas
même cette boule relou qui file juste
par carte et non c'est pas c'est pas
besoin tout le corps pour y arriver
allez ouvre toi all alone on attend et
des fruits mais ils mettent des lames
trop bien calculer c'est abusé en biais
là à la petite fdp mal éduqué ses marais
parti aujourd'hui qu'elles ont été dures
mais la difficulté grande aide what a ok
je voyais avoir passé ok faut qu'il
s'est du coup aux médias savent où nous
trouver
calmons nous sommes ok on y est c'est
parti suivre à ok en fait passé entre
les deux trucs qui alla
presque prêt sans quoi c'est la magie
droit mais non mais du coup on a réussit
pas mais non n'ai aucune crainte à la
voyez il faut passer pile entre les deux
mais c'est dur attend mais regarder mais
je veux faire quoi
ok j'en vois ma tête elle peut pas
exploser elle est trop puissante et
voilà elle exploser
mais que je vais péter un câble je pète
un camélia et après j'ai une idée mal ça
va mal ça au battant on a réussi la
géniale oh là là quelle idée de génie
c'est dur un oh merde ça peut arriver de
partout en fait je deviens parano
bah voilà ol est passé vraiment très
près elle était avec nous
gravel équipe qu'est ce que c'est que ça
stay in the light au hockey pas projet
moi tu me le dis - violences semblaient
pippa pippa poux je reste dans la
lumière je suis quelqu'un de gentil
temps c'est super dur là mais en fait je
me fais snipe et s'ils changent la
lumière c'est abusé regardez nous amène
au plus haut voire et afia un marteau et
un marteau et un marteau il m'aura pas
il mourra pas il mourra pas et voilà non
je suis pas mort mais un bug départ trop
marrant à temps on a cassé le jeu moi
c'est quoi ça hein d'accord avec tout
doucement et s'habituer au hockey
d'accord je vois passer bana ba voila ou
non [ __ ] sa lumière hossa spidla
à lakota le mec à la lumière et s'est
réveillée à je vais trop vite je les
trouvais diderot talent je me désole
vraiment je suis désolée qu'elle n'est
pas mal ok c'est stressant
tu sais que si tu mets un pas dans
l'ombre d'humeur direct là mais le truc
comment il fait mon gars ça regardez
regardez jean michel francky qui
s'amusent à la light quoi au [ __ ] je
te baise moi qui allais allez stop le
front qu'il te plaît
mais enfin tout ça j'en ai marre voilà
oui mais non c'est un sketch où j'ai
passé vite
je sens qu'on va y arriver là je sens
qu'on n'est pas mauvais il ya un marteau
et un marteau [ __ ] il m'a mais nous ça
partout il arrive on va se mettre la
hausse alors [ __ ] allait stopper les
budgets coin de la journée marc j'en
peux plus je suis stressé de qu au nom
j'adore quand ça bug alors ça ça bug
j'adore les bugs mais ça a le seul moyen
aux dames c'est trop tard l'album high
tech jamais checkpoint à léo continue
level 11 c'est parti là laser ou trauma
d'accord là il ya des lasers au chaos
[ __ ] ils veulent pas au québec la tête
à mon avis au bout c'est une cible a
chuté avec sa tête et bat n'ont même pas
les checkpoints va y avoir des lasers
embuscade ou pas non c'est bon pas de
lasers et celle pas aller à gauche et
suscité à droite totalement ok alors hop
la pop là maintenant et ben voilà ça
c'est fait arnaud pires anlage peut plus
parler la truck centration à la hausse
cet élan de ce qu'il c'est exceptionnel
ok ça part en steaks
ça peut penser oh là là où quand comment
la voce là là là là aussi tout est beau
bien joué j'ose même faire des roulades
hockey dernier level hockey voyais plus
mon visage
ben voilà maintenant leur voix et si
vous êtes content moi oui voilà
à petit près choses à temps se passer
durant ce niveau 1 en train de le rocher
de ouf
high stakes vous savez quoi on est
tellement d où ont été demandés où va
même faire ça ou alors on n'a pas le
temps check point où aller alors ça ça
c'est ce qui a vous tous les biais du
jeu dans son souviens bien c'est
extrêmement simple pires coupe du monde
on est bon
une plateforme 15 arénas au hockey ce
parti olalala y aller vite mais non ce
passera avant fille et ses jambes sont
les gens pas besoin de gens pataugent en
battant mais c'est carrément bien au
fait du coup on n'est au fond pas son
souhait laser attend ce génial à cette
stratégie-là olalalala alors là si tu je
dis oh mon dieu oh mon dieu oh mon dieu
non enfin drôle à
et voilà on a fait tous les lovell
[ __ ] moi et j'en suis à 27,2 habito
sur band aid sheeran
on laisse la chance on va ce qu'il fait
là dessus n'hésitez pas mais là deux
césar fut construite dans une prochaine
c'est un excellent jeu choix qui coûte
10 euros franchement pour 10 euros c'est
super tout ça c'est grave le tape un
petit coup de coeur je vous avoue merci
à vous la retrouverez pursuit rêver dans
une prochaine vidéo
non non non
à quelques heures de l'ouverture des
miettes de l'office